the film opens up in 2019 with Chicago
under martial law due to a worldwide
extraterrestrial Invasion the Drummond
family tries to escape the city and
breaches a barricade only to face the
Extraterrestrial beings tragically the
parents are killed by the aliens sparing
only the two sons Gabriel and Rafe fast
forward to the year 2028 the world has
surrendered to the alien legislators
submitting to their governance that is
the aliens have full Authority and
control over the humans police working
for the legislators are wide spread to
control anyone who revolts against the
existing government digital
communication has been shut down and
people are forced to live under
continuous monitoring furthermore humans
are enlisted to build closed zones
underground habitats for the aliens with
access only granted to and by high
government officials aliens have also
placed a chip on the neck of every human
being so that they can have complete
information about humans the next scene
shows Rafe the older brother from the
Drummond family whose parents were
murdered by the aliens in 2019 having
witnessed witness the gruesome death of
his parents Rafe hates aliens he leads a
resistance group called Phoenix group
through which he has been waging a war
against the extr terrestrials he is
determined to eliminate the aliens and
avenge his parents' death meanwhile the
aliens want to find The Hideout of the
group and Destroy them completely sadly
Rafe Is tragically killed during one of
his coups against the Invaders following
this rafe's little brother Gabriel
Drummond living in the impoverished
pelson neighborhood prepares to leave
for Lake City after his brother's death
he is certain that the alien alens will
come after him so he plans to go to a
safer place that is Lake City in the
meantime the aliens have hired a Chicago
Police Special Branch Commander
detective William Mulligan to find the
Phoenix group it is revealed that
detective William had partnered with
Gabriel's father before The Invasion one
day the detective visits a brel which
has been marked by the Phoenix group's
logo there he meets a lady named Jane do
who tries to be intimate with him in the
subsequent scene the detective returns
to his workplace where a board displays
an array of Clues these Clues suggest
that the Phoenix group remains active
with a mission to destroy the current
government attempting to persuade his
partner grommet the detective emphasizes
that the resistance group is still
operational underground he asserts that
the group is utilizing classified
devices for communication however
grommet remains skeptical dismissing
William's claims and arguing that he is
merely Chasing Ghosts despite this
William is determined to prove his
partner wrong therefore he monitors
Gabriel raf's little brother for the
next couple of days then one day he
drives down the pilson neighborhood
where the teenager lives Gabrielle is
then confronted by the detective who
asks him various questions regarding the
Phoenix group he wants to extract as
much information as possible from the
teenager William is convinced that the
Phoenix resistance group has not been
neutralized contrary to what the public
has been told but Gabriel offers him no
information detective William also
offers Gabriel to work with him however
the teenager refuses to do so and walks
away it is revealed that the detective
has been keeping an eye on the teenager
through a GPS tracker subsequently he
discreetly watches Gabriel's actions
from his office keeping a Vigilant eye
on the teenagers whereabouts and
interactions with others later that day
Gabriel meets with a cooworker who gives
him a hand rolled cigarette containing
secret information on the Phoenix group
The cooworker then advises him to go to
a specific location having arrived at
the location the teenager meets with a
member of the resistance group the man
then takes him to Wicker Park a
completely abandoned place there he
meets his supposedly Dead Brother Rafe
Rafe explains that after his last
attempt to eliminate the aliens failed
terribly he has been faking his death to
the aliens so that he wouldn't be found
he has also removed the GPS tracker chip
from his neck therefore now nobody knows
his whereabouts Rafe then takes the
coated cigarette and directs Gabriel to
leave the city as Phoenix plans to
attack the upcoming Unity rally at a
place called Soldier Field the unity
rally will have the presence of
highlevel government officials including
the mayor who obey the aliens in their
governance the group's agenda is to kill
all the aliens and the officials
associated with them at once Rafe
insists Gabriel leave as soon as
possible because he doesn't want his
little brother to get hurt during the
attack rushing to his apartment Gabriel
swiftly packs his belongings but once
again encounters detective William the
detective had been discreetly keeping
tabs on him although the teenager
skillfully evades the detective he finds
himself trapped in an underground lair
in the meantime Rafe and his team work
to infiltrate the unity rally where not
everyone is invited thankfully the
cigarettes code allows them to access
Chicago's surveillance system and the
deployment patterns of law enforcement
units it also allows them to know the
whereabouts of the specific government
officials and the positions of the
aliens moreover the resistance group
also has an invisible alien explosive
device which if taken anywhere will not
be detected as soon as the device is
activated it becomes invisible since the
members of the Phoenix group have their
GPS tracker removed from their necks
they can easily carry out their Coupe
they start by by going after such
government officials who are invited to
the rally they kill them extract the
chips from their bodies and then insert
them inside their own this means that
the resistance members use the obtained
chips to gain access to the rally in the
next scene Rafe and fellow Phoenix
members launch an attack on the unity
rally deploying the unnoticeable alien
explosive device against the
extraterrestrials upon their arrival as
a result many alien forces as well as
people who are loyal to them are killed
following the explosion the Phoenix
members start driving away the rest of
the people from the rally meanwhile the
aliens summon more of their allies and
begin retaliating detective William who
works for the alien government learns
about the Phoenix attack and conveys the
information to his superiors while the
initial strike seems effective the city
is soon placed under lockdown with
security forces joining in response
enraged by the continuing attack the
aliens summon hunters from another world
to identify and apprehend the culprits
in the pursuit Rafe and his accompli
Anita and Daniel are cornered Anita is
dis integrated while Daniel opts for a
cyanide pill to evade capture however
before Rafe can take his cyanide pill he
is shot and apprehended by detective
William at the same time Gabriel manages
to emerge from the underground lair only
to find out that the police have
destroyed his Escape boat following this
he is also taken into custody along with
his brother Rafe at the police station
Detective Williams shows Gabriel his
brother being tortured for information
he wants the teenager to find the
Mastermind the supposed ring leader
behind the Phoenix group giv in his
brother's battered condition Gabriel is
forced to oblige to the detective's
instructions William then convinces him
to send a message through the Phoenix
Network in hopes of meeting the ring
leader number one in the next scene
Gabriel goes to the Phoenix group's
headquarters and tells the members that
he has special information for number
one after hearing this the members take
him to their Master's Place Gabriel
follows the trail and discovers Jane do
a prostitute running a brothel in pilson
she unexpectedly recognizes him by name
leaving him bewildered it turns out that
Jane is The Mastermind behind the
Phoenix group what's more shocking is
that detective William along with other
highlevel government officials is her
usual client a police raid soon ensues
resulting in Jane's tragic demise
subsequent investigations uncover that
Jane had secretly bugged her own
residence capturing conversations with
special Branch members and extracting
classified information the recorded
tapes also expose Police Commissioner
Eugene aigo for disclosing sensitive
details about the extraterrestrials
arrival at soier field enabling Phoenix
to seize explosive Alien Devices and
prepare a perfect attack strategy by
means of prostitution she would wiretap
classified conversations and learn
important details about the alien
government one night when the mayor of
the city visited her she overheard him
talking about the code that would give
access to the unity rally Jane then
shared this critical information with
her resistance members due to which they
were able to infiltrate the unity rally
and kill dozens of aliens consequently
iigo along with raef and several others
is deported off world that is they are
transported to a separate alien planet
for further punishment following this
detective William having declared the
Chicago threat neutralized earns a
promotion to acting commissioner in a
private meeting between the detective
and Gabriel the latter expresses regret
over raf's unsuccessful plan the
teenager is also guilty of working for
the police because he blames himself for
number one's death now he worries that
his brother who had been planning
something very big might be dead all
their efforts spanning decades seem to
have turned into a failure detective
William retrieving a box previously
obtained from Jane unveils a Blackberry
phone and hands the memory card to
Gabriel he then hints that perhaps
failure was part of the plan Gabriel
later examines the cards contents
discovering a video capturing his own
baby shower to his surprise the footage
reveals that Jane Doe had connections to
his mother having taught at the same
school this means that Jane and his
mother used to be friends this is also
the reason why Jane was able to
recognize Gabriel when she first saw him
earlier the video concludes with scenes
from the baby shower where detective
William introduces himself alongside
several Phoenix members it turns out
that the detective has been a member of
the resistance group all along he then
leaves a message for Gabriel encouraging
the teenager to carry on the legacy of
Phoenix Gabriel realizes that he now has
to lead the Phoenix group and continue
its mission in the meantime detective
William receives approval to Rendevous
underground with the legislators the
underground known as the closed zone is
where the aliens live and only high
level officers are allowed to enter it
having been promoted to an acting
commissioner positioned the detective is
now allowed to go to the closed Zone as
he descends he grabs onto the alien
explosives invisible substance it
becomes evident that the apparent
failure of the attack plan in the unity
rally was a meticulously orchestrated
Ploy the failure allowed the detective
to gain the trust of the alien
government consequently being promoted
to a commissioner level now the big and
ultimate plan is to launch the potent
explosive device in the closed Zone from
where all the AL aliens operate since it
is the base for the alien government
destroying it would mean a potential win
against the aliens after he reaches the
closed Zone Detective Williams swiftly
activates the device delivering a
decisive and fatal blow to the
legislators following this the aliens
all over the planet begin to lose their
grip as they are all connected to the
closed Zone some are destroyed to the
ground While others are weakened in the
credits a map illustrates the successful
destruction of the Chicago closed Zone
accompanied by reports of additional
resistance strikes and protests erupting
in cities worldwide